Salut c'est Cyrus, et si je suis ici, ce n'est pas pour un Coup de Phil mais c'est pour vous remercier
parce que vous êtes plus de 5000 abonnés
sur la chaine donc je trouve ça, vraiment très stylé et je suis très content
j'ai pas mal de retour positif aussi, donc, très encourageant y'a des gens qui ont lus des ouvrages de philo après les vidéos
Il y'a des profs de philo qui montrent les vidéos en cours, enfin, bref, c'est génial !
et du coup, je voulais vous remercier en répondant à vos questions de philosophie
des questions philosophiques que l'on peut se poser, et je sais que sa pourrait être sympa si j'essayais d'y répondre
en tout cas, que l'on en discute ensemble. Donc du coup je vais poster cette vidéo sur Facebook
et dans les commentaires du post de la vidéo, vous posez vos questions et moi je ferais une autre vidéo où je répondrais à vos questions.
donc, du coup cette vidéo elle est un peu éphémère, je vais la laisser quelques semaines le temps d'avoir assez de questions
et puis je ferais une vidéo réponse, pour vous remercier. Voilà, merci encore.
Du love et de la peace